everyone's got a story to tell
everyone's got a great idea you know
experiment you know
and if you and a few people are finding
this game really fun then i'm sure like
chris says that that niche audience will
be there
we founded the company way back in 2008
and um
how i got into that i guess um from my
graduate course i was doing web design
um and way back then there was kind of a
thing called flash and i was making a
lot of flash games um for for
advertising companies for um
you know if someone wanted to create
their brand a little game you could play
online was quite um was part of the
the sales pitch so um doing that i was
also with my business partner luke he
was also in a similar
um
career sort of making these flash games
and we just um
you know we enjoy doing this but we
wanted to strike out on our own um so we
carried on
making games for clients but in the
background we were kind of making our
own
game and even at that time we were
making it not sure what we were going to
um
do with it but um we just felt like it
would be really like
we wanted to make games slightly
differently a lot of our games have hand
crafted elements and then
so while making these client based games
we made a game called loom which was um
all made by paper and craft um with an
animated character running around we
filmed it in a friend's bedroom really
really low budget really low scale
and when we did that we then decided to
let's just put it on steam and see what
happens back then um
steam you know only had a handful of
indie games and we were lucky enough
around that like 2010 2011 kind of
first independent game companies um to
be in that
bunch and so loom went on to um
to kind of pay for itself and more and
gave us this independence that we didn't
know we could do we could make a game
in this small studio and we can
we can launch it i started in the
industry back in
96
i'd always wanted to work in
games so
i managed to land a job in a what what
we would now call it a little indie
company um straight out of university um
and that gave me a leg up to get a job
at ea for a couple of years i worked at
intelligent games and then around about
the millennium i settled down at
traveller's tales just before they
released the first lego star wars
so
over the next 15 years or so i worked on
most of the
lego series
up until the point where we finally did
uh lego dimensions uh i spent a lot of
time working on the doctor who elements
of lego dimensions uh and then i felt
i'd peaked uh so uh
set up uh
my company quantum soup studios
in 2016 and uh it's it's been
an interesting um experience a little
bit rocky uh
my original um game um i couldn't manage
to find a publisher for so we had to
pivot to do a bit of work for hire and
then uh our current project which
it's gonna i'm gonna have to be cagey
about because it's unannounced um our
current project is a licensed game that
i did manage to get a publisher for so
we we've
it's been a little bit of a
windy road uh to where we are today but
we're currently working on a licensed
game with a big eye ip
for families uh which i'm very excited
about what do you think were the
benefits of
striking out and starting on your own
what was the difference between
working for your own studio and working
for another agency like tt or ea
yeah it's
swings and roundabouts that
there are pros and cons um my lead at tt
had run a company um for a while uh and
and unfortunately it had through like
no fault of his it had um it had failed
i'd never experienced
that so
i'd only had that laser focus and i was
keen to
to
have
a chance to make more creative decisions
um so
i was quite excited to be able to go
like right this is the this is the thing
that um
that i want to do
that also was a bit of a learning
experience because the first thing that
i wanted to do was um a
a bit quirky and b
a bit too ambitious uh and as a result
um i couldn't get uh i couldn't land a a
deal for that one so so i had to um
pivot and um
do things differently for a little bit
uh and that was a little bit of a
difficult
uh
time because
you know
it made me question some of my uh
decisions
but
i feel like
i was able to turn it around so this
this project feels like it's much of
a much better bet commercially
uh than that original one i want to go
back to that original one because i
still think that it's a it's got legs
but it's something that i think that i'm
probably going to have to put some of my
own money into rather than um trying to
pitch it to somebody else benefits were
the again and chris has sort of touched
on this the creative freedom you have
with creating your own um
your own project and and you know
whatever happens it it's on it's on you
i mean it's it's tough and i always
think the beginning of the game process
is very exciting and you think but
getting a game over the line and
published and you know you've got [ __ ]
you've got scheduling issues
hr issues you've got
is this even a good idea anymore issues
um you know that that's really tough and
it and it's very it can be very
stressful and you always need to kind of
make sure you're looking after your
yourself and your team and you know
um
just um
yeah
that's that's really tough we
self-publish as well so we're not even
relying on a publisher um
for for our games i mean that that kind
of freedom and i think with the
knowledge and the you know
doing it 15 years we kind of we hope we
know how to
make a state of play game and how and
how to to get it done so so it's a
really exciting that um kind of hey i
want to tell a story and i want an
audience to see it so so yeah that that
was a real benefit for us i'm going to
start with chris on this um and if it's
not too brutal a question
you know what does it cost to set up on
your own do you need a savings pot do
you think you have to have a day job i'm
sure you don't because you didn't i
think one of the mistakes that i made
was i was a little bit too ambitious
early on i was targeting sort of like um
projects that would like have a budget
of about half a mil
um
and that sits in a weird no man's land
between
like
micro indie games where publishers are
quite happy to
throw sort of like um 50 grand or 100
grand at like a solo developer who's got
a really cool quirky project
um because that's pocket change to them
um
but once you get up to the like
half a mil to a mill that gets into the
range where it's still a cheap project
in in in the scheme of things it sounds
like a lot um
it goes in no time um
uh they're not really interested uh
unless you until you get up to the sort
of like um six to ten million budget uh
where you you then need sort of like a
big team and that's complicated i tried
to get sort of like go into that sort of
like the middle of that no man's land
because i didn't really
have um a lot of experience with uh with
project budgets
um that felt like it would be a
comfortable sort of like team size and
budget size um
uh
for me
at the time but it didn't really fit
with what publishers um were looking for
and also it carried a bit of a risk
because
i was
trying to uh go from sort of like
full-time employment to full-time
employment and i needed to have some
sort of budget in place i think it's
probably
smarter to do it the way that catherine
has done it which is like starting with
something that was sort of like
a working business first and then sort
of like transitioning into into
something more creative gradually
without taking such a big
risk
um i don't know if you agree with that
kath i don't know i don't know if we've
done it the right way
well that's tell us but but yeah i mean
again like i mentioned before like i
guess generally as a company we've been
quite risk averse and um quite early on
um i've got an excellent
mentor in the industry who's a veteran
um kind of games developer and he just
turned to me and went keep your overhead
slow
and it's probably the best piece of
advice
someone's ever given me because
basically
yeah each project we
you know with teams of two if that goes
well with team of four it's like you
know so we've we've scaled up in a very
manageable way and you know um
we haven't relied on publishing money
it's been our own money but then again
the profits have all been our own money
um so yeah we've we've um
we've really scaled up that way um
and
it it seems to have seems to work for us
it actually leads us on quite nicely to
the next section which is about
investors um i think that's an area that
lots of um budding developers
um
feel that there's quite a lot of
information about investing out there so
if you google how to find investment
you'll be in inundated with with
uh with helpful articles but it's also a
bit of a a mystery because
you know we all know that these things
are quite often fortuitous it's quite
often to do with connections is quite
often to do with someone you may have
bumped in with to someone at gdc or
something did you set up a vertical
slice of your game and then and then
take that round we've worked um a lot
with with com you know platforms such as
apple and again we've done when we're
sort of showing them the next game we've
done things like vertical slice of the
game and a pitch and so that's probably
how we get them interested in the game
show in as much as you can is always
great but again
don't invest a year of your time
into a game that you're then going to
pitch you know it's sort of like sort of
getting the balance right about giving
enough to get people interested but
obviously you don't want to be
working for free for years on a game
hoping
to get some investment once i started
pitching games i did find that
the fact that i got like 20 years of
experience in the industry
didn't really count for very much uh in
the context of pitching a particular
game it was all about um uh
okay so what's the game um who's it for
um have you got a demo that we can play
um
that that is all
they're interested in i suspect that
sort of like my background did help sort
of like
kind of like gloss over a bunch of
questions that they might have like
asked um a less experienced developer um
but it certainly
didn't just sort of like magically open
the door sort of like oh okay you know
what you're doing then great have some
money
which is kind of what i was hoping for
uh and that very much did not happen uh
so it is you have to show
what you want to what you want to make
vertical slices are a bit and just demos
in general um are a bit of a pain
because uh but it is so useful to build
something like that so that you can uh
show its people and and get feedback on
it so
it is it is very satisfying to have
people play your demo and go sort of
like
yes i would definitely buy that game
when's it done it's like
when somebody will pay us to finish it
but the next question i'd like to ask
you about is is marketing and finding an
audience
and gaming is is an exceptionally
competitive and in some instances and i
say this with love over saturated
markets particularly for certain games
in certain sub genres so i'd love to
know how you you know do you start with
an audience and you know an ideal
audience and work your way backwards do
you start with the game idea and then
try and hope you find an audience how do
you go about that i guess for us we kind
of start with the idea first i mean i
i'd like to think
we're never just kind of making it in a
vacuum of like this is a game we want to
make you know don't care if anyone likes
it obviously you're always trying to
make a game that there is an audience
for but i think you can
like
i think a really good tip is to be
authentic to yourself and if you are
just kind of playing a numbers game of
like well
18 to 24 year olds like these so we need
you know it's gonna come out in the end
result and and you're not gonna enjoy
making it either
um a game takes a long time to make and
you know make sure it's something you
want to wake up every morning to
and and and
make it you know the biggest marketing
tool for us
if i'm being really honest is awards and
especially
um the bafta we weren't from luminos
city we got that before it launched on
um ios um so it was on pc one of after
and two months later
came out on ios so straight away
it was after award-winning game you know
they kind of told its own story
um which we were incredibly incredibly
grateful for so for people starting out
i really recommend you know if you feel
like your game's good it's always worth
worth a shot at just entering i'm
interested in making games um i have
no particular sort of like skill at um
at selling them uh so
my uh
plan has always been to work with a
publisher who knows what they're doing
um the publishers
have the like the budget and the
knowledge to sort of like get
a a given project in front of the
audience who will be interested um in it
um
what catherine says is right though
about um
you generally
you don't want to go chasing uh
chasing a trend or something because
that is going to put you in competition
with literally everybody else if your
ambition is to sort of like try to sort
of like compete with fortnight that's a
high bar to hit
um so
as a small company um particularly as a
startup company you're better off doing
something that is um
uh a bit different you can find a niche
audience but a niche audience is usually
enough to support a small company um and
you can grow from there um but actually
having kind of like doing something a
little bit different is is a good way to
um to be known there's no point trying
to
copy an amazing
game idea that's already out there doing
really well well there's no point
copying any game because it's you know
it's already out there everyone's got a
story to tell everyone's got a great
idea you know experiment you know
and if you and a few people are finding
this game really fun then i'm sure like
chris says that that niche audience will
be there
you